OK那就是刚才讲的就是经过我们这个欧伯叔的主题分享大家一定对他的成长很感兴趣了那我们就来聊一聊他是怎么样去成长为一个拥有26000的一个开源大流的OK那第一个点肯定是我觉得这是一切初心的开始嘛对吧为什么在那个时候我们其实有那么多方向你选择了做后端这个方向对可以给大家讲一下当时的一个
其实我大学学的专业是网络其实就是属于什么路由啊交换机啊这种硬片硬件一点的然后我当时对这些完全没有兴趣所以我就自己去从图书馆结束所以从最开始其实是从前端开始的我自己学CSSGS那个年代还是用table布局啊就几乎不流行DIV所以呢这种table布局的古老年代所以我一开始其实是从前端入门的那但是最后怎么遇到PP
做PPP呢其实是因为worldpress也就是大家都熟练了一个博客工具worldpress当时是想做一个自己的博客然后遇到问题就是用了一些主题想要把这个主题呢改改或者想在某个地方加个东西但是呢找不到人帮忙然后呢去那个主题坐着裙里边呢问问题还被喷了就是啊你自己不会解决吗我忙得很没空那种基本上就是这种状态于是呢
那好吧那就自己去解决于是就开始去看他的代码然后就开始去看PAP的文档等等那个时候基本上就是一步步摸过来因为那个时候基本上没有现在接各种视频教程因为我是90年的所以我说的这个时代是2010年左右所以那个时候是没有各种线上教程网站的所以所有东西几乎都是自己去摸去文档去试所以有时候一个问题可能卡一天都有可能
就这么摸出来呢于是就开始尝试终于把问题解决了以后呢就开始尝试做自己的主题就是worldpress主题以及worldpress插件我印象中我先后发布了六个主题吧以及七个插件好像当时还有很多大V啊就是在worldpress圈子那些大伯克的都用了我的插件所以觉得还是挺自好的一件事情所以严格来讲不是我选择了做后的而是误打误撞的就这么做到了
后来就觉得PB很信任嘛所以后来找工作呢也就就自然的就往这里走了ok所以所以你是属于那种嗯你你不帮我做就我自己来做对吧就是你不干我就把你都不干了哈哈哈对对对ok ok好这个这个其他挺有意思的所以其实也是属于在这个过程中吧就做了一个
就是根据自己的这个可能是遵从自己的内心嘛就是跟感觉自己喜欢这个东西然后就开始往这个方向上去转但但我就应该是一些项目是不是里面那些项目其实可能给到了你一些正向的反馈所以让你觉得有成就感有一些很好的成就感所以就往那个方向转对对对这里所以这里也是我想补充一点就是刚才刚才我们在讲第一页就是寻找创意的时候就是写代码那部分呃其实我们在做任何事情都是需要一些正反馈的那
你的在做这个过程当中我一直觉得就是如果我要做了我就一定要做得别人好所以就是这种所谓的不复书的感觉让我去去选择做这个事情为什么我重复造了那么多轮子就是因为我在用别人的开源项目的时候满足不了的需求然后给他反馈可能持持也没有想象所以才迫使我去做比他更好的一个东西做出来那这其实最后的结果就是你做的更好的话就会有更多的用那就会有更多的
这种所谓的影响力趋势你去做这个就是正反馈所以当你觉得你没有动力的时候你就去思考一下这个事情为什么我没有动力可能真的就是所谓的正反馈不足就是你的驱动力不够我还想说一句我们在找这个相创意的时候千万不要担心说我想做的东西已经有做了对吧那如果已经有人做了你可以去参与如果你参与不进去你也可以
你如果你有信心做的比他好那你就造一个比他更好的轮子不用担心造轮子的问题嗯对OK因为因为其实是个人项目嘛其实没有KPI对吧我们就在面对PPI的时候才会有说造轮子的问题是不是是是是是OK那我们其实也会讲到另外一个我们在每一次跟讲实聊的时候都会老生常谈的一个问题因为你也是从一个
可能是个新手开发者嘛就就你刚才讲了一些你从前端转到后端的一个故事但是可能大家会比较感兴趣比如说从你上学的时候开始啊就你到现在这样的一个阶段就每个阶段你是怎么样去成长的而且在每个阶段就是有没有一些相应的建议给到就是各个呃层级的同学吧嗯好呃其实我每次面试那些刚毕业的人的时候我最后都会
我都會問一個問題就是你想問我什麼他們想問我的問題基本都是這個問題就是希望我能給他一些在這個職業道路或是技術路線上的一些建議那基本上我也會講一下在我這個過程當中遇到的一些點或者是一些覺得對我有幫助的一些點那我最開始就是基本都是自學了剛才講的在大學怎麼去研究這些
最关键的点其实是13年的一份工作了因为其实其他的基本都和大家一样就是去取离问问题或者谷歌搜索
那这个搜索的过程最关键的一个点就是怎么寻找关键词因为很多人会直接用口语话的东西说怎么怎么怎么其实这个其实不是一个很高效的监索因为你面对的是一个机器人所以你就怎么用怎么用什么这些口语是没有意义的你直接上关键词就好了节省你达字的时间也能更精准的找到问题就是比如说你爆出你就贴爆出信息的关键部分就好了等等那所以就是一些寻找
解释所答案的一些技巧那另外就是一个关键的机会是13年的时候当时做我在博言科技做雅虎台湾的一个商城做那个商城的过程当中呢是跟台湾的技术负责人就是那边的那边的人负责我们的像质量所以呢我当时是一个小队的
因为当时领导觉得说我可能会比较会说一点就让我作为这个我们二分队的一个对接人我们一个队大概有二十来个人吧开发者有十几个所以呢每个队都会对应台湾那边的一个负责然后呢我就作为这个沟通人去把两边的问题去勾兑那这个过程当中呢我作为沟通人还是同时还是开发环境的维护者
就是我们那个年代还没有Docker但是雅虎已经有一个类似Docker的东西叫做Yroot然后那个环境呢所有的问题他们遇到都是找我去解决实际上很多问题也是我在解决的过程当中自己去搜不出来答案解决的但是由于我解决过一遍了所以最后形成这个习惯下来就是我每天就是在不同的工位之间跑来跑去帮他们修环境那这个结果呢就是锻炼了我对这个Ninux环境啊一些基础问题的解决然后呢
另外我还需要做一件事情就是编写技术文档那这个技术文档是什么呢因为那个项目的要求是每做一个需求都需要把这个需求从需求描述到技术构成到和一些结果交互需要那些评证代码怎么放各种细节全部都要把它列到一篇文档才能开工那基本上就是换句话说去你把这个需求交给任何一个人看了这份文档
它都能接下来所以要达到这样的要求所以那个时候就锻炼了我怎么去消化一个需求怎么去设计一个接口实现的一个能力的过程那这个过程大概持续了11个月左右所以我觉得这是我在技术路线当中成长最快的因为这当中还有非常让人难以接受的部分就是它的编码要求非常严格在国内我至少没有找到第二家有这么严格的公司就是
比如说我们在prc当中经常写的一个数组嘛arrake什么什么什么如果你的数字超过两个元素你必须要写成两方必须要呃就是元素的第一个字符必须和areare对齐就是一个空格都不能少就精准到这种程度所以他们的代码规范都是用工具去机器测量的一旦格式错误或者哪里多了空白哪里没有对齐
那个邮件就会自动发到你的leader那里去所以超级严格我们花了四五个月才适应一下这种氛围最后在这过程中作为沟通人断练了我的沟通技巧同时还有要写技术文档所以在书写和表达能力上都得到了非常大的提升但是我还是觉得是不够好另外就是到后面从内加公司离开以后我去的也是一家外部公司那时候是独自负责项目
那这个独自到什么范围呢就是跟着产品经理去北京电视台跟对方聊需求然后背着电脑过去听他们讲他们想要做什么东西那最后回来到公司自己设计完一个草稿最后呢我独自一个人再拿着我的草稿板再去他们那边跟他们确认啊这个文章发布是不是标签要支持一对多等等就是各种什么细节的确认确认完了以后再回来再写代码写完代码自己设计数据库最后到完成到部署
到上线就是总监只给你几台机器然后你就自己把它串起来让它能跑起来因为那个时候云服务其实还并没有那么发达所以基本上都是什么数据库各种工具全都自己打最后再把这几台十几台机器串起来做成一个完整的项目所以在这个过程当中也是锻炼了一个综合能力那最后呢就是到手机微博了15年的时候手机微博的老大也交给我一个非常挺大的一个坑就是
要重寫整个手机微博的接口大概480多个接口吧那怎么重写呢他给我的一句话就是不要用原来代码的不要用原来项目的一行代码为什么呢因为他自己也非常痛恨那个项目就是我们现在接到一个非常小的需求至少都需要两三天或者一周才能做因为历史的代码实在是太优种而且
经过了好多年的版本所以没有办法再去迭代所以做一个非常小的需求都需要花很久的时间去确认测试所以他说千万不要用以前的旧单于是我就花了一年多的时间将那个项目底层就是基础结构包括怎么样方便大家写测试怎么华大家写业务逻辑的部分做了一个
完全地重寫花了一年半的時間最後我拉上10個開發者花了兩個月時間把480多個接口基本上就簽完了所以我覺得這個還是有一定的進步在這個過程上就非常挑戰對代碼重構和設計的能力因為你需要去把原來的東西都要看懂這個就非常費勁舉個例子大家平常在手機衣服上發微博這麼一個接口看起來非常簡單的一個動作但是我花了整整兩個週一邊寫筆記一邊記
才能把那个逻辑看明白非常夸张那这个基本就是我在这个过程当中所遇到了一些挑战和一些机遇我觉得这些虽然很痛苦但是绝对是你成长过程当中的助推技就是你不去躺这些坑你也就不可能进步得这么快所以不要害怕问题那实际上就是利用各种挑战的机会去发挥吧我觉得如果要总结一句话的话就应该是这样
非常非常非常受用因为这里讲到刚才其实欧巴厨你应该带过公司也挺多的大大小小的公司对吧然后同学应该是第六家对大大小的公司都有嘛所以就一定会面临一个很多开发者也会问的一个问题就是我们讲这个鸡头和氛围我应该打打打个引号的没有打不好意思因为外面有引号所以我就没打了到底要怎么样去选
嗯嗯这个这个问题确实是一个非常好的问题因为很多就是比如说刚毕业的人他拿到了不同的offer他也是很难去做抉择就是应该去哪里去这个小厂呢工资高一点但是可能人少一点很多学不到动机去大厂呢可能工资低一点但是名字好听一点那这个东西的各有它的利弊但是呢从我这么多呆了这么多大大小小的公司
算下来也带了三家大公司吧然后三家小公司三四家小公司首先我不告诉你怎么选但是我可以提供一些我发现的问题对吧首先就是大厂其实没有你想象的那么完美其实大厂的问题可能比小厂的更多对吧因为我们都知道就像人口或是团队归我一旦大起来就必然会面临很多管理的问题那比如说在腾讯
将近10万个员工你觉得你能统一一个技术站吗或者你能统一个规范吗是不可能的所以说越大的厂可能遇到的坑越多因为很多历史遗留是没有人能改的动的甚至说你有那个心你都没有办法去完成有气无力甚至可能你的老板甚至不让你去动因为他现在好好的你动可能就动崩了千一发而动全身因为很多历史遗留在里面
所以對大廠來講如果你一定要去大廠的話那就一定要挑團隊比如說這個團隊的負責人怎麼樣他怎麼看待技術怎麼看待代碼怎麼看待規範等等然後就是小廠其實也有非常好的地方那比如說他做任何一個決策可能都比較容易因為沒有那麼多歷史遺留那甚至呢我也見過好幾個
非常小美的那种团队他们用的工具啊还有代码规范啊甚至选型啊等等都是非常专业的因为他们可以随时去调节所以他可以在很短的时间内得到一个非常完美的架构所以小的团队也有他的好处但是这个就是对于应接生活的时候钢币的人来讲筛选能力会有很大的挑战那这个一般就是建议说看能不能尽可能的
找熟人幫你瞭解比如說在那待過的人給個評價或者說是看看他們公司在業界有沒有一些相關的技術的影響力等等就是所以如果去小廠就一定要關注這個工程師氛圍然後使用的什麼開發環境規範等等以及技術服務的人怎麼看那如果去大團隊的話首先你本身你就是為了可能大部分人就是為了這個民意
然後另外一部分人可能是為了去裡面學到東西因為很多大廠確實他有足夠的錢去找很多優秀的人進來但是有一個非常關鍵的點就是很多人一直覺得說我想要去大廠跟人學什麼東西我覺得千萬不要有這個觀點這是個我非常不贊同的一個點別人沒有那麼多的時間去教你的實際上你真正學東西實際上是從彩坑和做需求
提煉出来的而不是某个大牛在那里所以你去你就能变得更优秀他就有空交你其实是没有的对所以如果机头氛围的话你就看你自己怎么选了比如说你有个非常明确的职业规划我要先去大厂度金然后再去什么什么地方最后我要去二三线等等那这个就是你自己路线的问题那各自都有他的好坏所以大厂可能他的代码写的真的很
很垃圾垃圾也是非常正常的不要觉得说他们的招聘要求高就一定能抓到非常厉害的人这个是错误的观点这个关系我也很赞同因为因为确实我们我们两年纪其实是差是差不多的嘛然后我也也是各种各样类型的公司也带过然后大的小的都有反正确实是他是一个取舍的问题吧就你可能他不会说有一个东西是绝对好的
也不会有一个东西是绝对坏的就你可能想要获得一些东西就要舍弃一些东西对吧只是说但但我觉得就是像奥伯厨因为他你有很多的经验嘛所以你讲这些东西我觉得都是一些很关键的点然后这点我觉得只是说我们通过这样的一个问题把这些点传达给我们直播间的一些相对来说比较
Junior的同学然后他们就可以通过这个你的你给他的一些信息然后去能帮助他们更好的做判断我觉得也是很有价值的嗯ok对那我觉得这个问题结束之后我觉得下一个问题会更加有意思啊就是因为这个我觉得和博初应该也很多的想法对于这个问题因为我们之前私下饶过嘛对所以我觉得今天你给你再讲一讲好那
从开发者变成负责人应该如何适应实际上在我们这边很多时候是不会给你一些title的我们虽然的直级很便宜
各种态度都是很变贫的但是当你要去做一件事情的时候并不会说我给你加工资给你一个很响亮的态度等的是没有的所以很多时候其实就是觉得你有这个能力你不要主动你有 owner意识那就可能就让你去负责一下所以当你作为一个从一个普通的开发者接需求做需求的开发者变成一个负责人的时候你要做的事情更多的是什么更多的是一个
統籌的事情那首先第一點就是時間會變得非常的零散就是你要去參加不同的會議你需要去跟不同的人溝通還要去幫助一些新來的開發者去幫他解決問題等等那你所有的時間可能都會打得非常的零散那第二個點就是你的溝通的圈子會變大因為你在
可能你原来做需求的时候就是给你提个需求单你就按了那个需求单去实现就好了你不用去管这个产品为什么不合理或者这里是不是可以调一下可以换一种实验方式等等你不会去想那么多或者说你想你也不想去跟人去思那你变成负责人或者是你变成一个项目经理以后你就会变得更有责任去把这个事情推得更合理
比如說產品經理可能提了一個東西你覺得不合理那你在會議上你在做的過程當中或者在你的那些開發者反饋問題的時候你需要去把這個事情給搞明白就是它確實不合理的話比如說當有人開發起來會實現比較困難那可能是設計不太合理那你需要去
去跟產品經理亞根老闆跟項目經理甚至前後端還有跟測試同學要去勾兌要去討論說我們是不是可以有更好的一個方案來解決這個問題現在的實現可能會有安全問題或者說是很便利或者花的時間可能比想像的長等等那你的這個勾通圈子就會非常大你需要去跟不同類型的人去勾兌另外就是你需要有一個更好的需求消化能力和設計能力那怎麼去理解這個問題呢就是當
可能你最终你没有写那么多代码对吧因为可能都是你带的人去写但是呢你在参与这个项目评审会的时候任何一个点你都是要专注去听的当某个需求项目经理在介绍的时候或产品经理在介绍交互啊介绍这个设计的时候你就要去想这背后应该是怎么样去实现会不会有坑的地方那你就需要去提出来所以你需要有一个非常丰富的需求设计能力你才能知道这个东西如果这么做是不是会有坑
因为如果你没有那么多经验的话你是不知道这么做一句会有可能的可能等你把代码写完上线了几个月才发现啊完了改不动对吧你才会传承不停地去推翻自己的设计的问题所以通常要想变成负责人的话或者说是变成一个核心开发者的话那至少需要非常多的需要做过非常多的需求吧你才能有那么多经验所以我经常在评审会上就是负责跟交互和产品私问题的人
甚至很多需求可能都是我去给他们挡住因为不是所有的需求你都需要做的合理的确实有好吃的你才需要做因为我们都知道人是有各种要人对吧有些需求做出来背定真的是合适的所以呢这种时候你还需要去负责帮他们做挡键牌然后呢需要更大的格局去看问题那这个就是讲的是什么呢你在拒绝一个需求或者说你在接受一个需求的时候你需要往前往后都要去看
比如说首先你要考虑的是时间方案上会不会牵扯到一些第三方或者说前段时间比较困难甚至说我做完以后后面没法扩展等等你需要从更远更长的时间去想这个问题因为很多我们在做
普通开发者或者是做需求消化者的时候我们可能就做完就不管了我才不管他有没有什么扩展性的问题呢对吧产品这么设计我就这么干嘛但是你如果作为负责人你就需要考虑说怎么能让你这个代码不是那么快的烂掉因为我们项目已经差不多四年了那现在我们的代码每一个新人进来都能在一周内上手我觉得这个还是蛮比较自豪的一个地方就是代码没有变烂没有变抽可能就是我长期
去保持這個需求的合理性以及擴展性的考量來保證它的質量所以這一點是非常難的包括我現在已經看到了一些很多問題是比較難解決的不過我們都還是在求各種機會去把它重構或者說是去找設計做一些妥協然後換一些更優的方案去實現等等來保證這個項目的質量所以這個是角色變化帶來的一些區別吧
我觉得那个偶尔处你讲的其实是一个比较常见的一个过程但我觉得可以对于这种刚来的那些开发者来说我觉得有个比较重要的点就是讲那个ownership的问题吧就我们讲ownership它其实是一个它不是一个权力吧就当你为你当负责人之后其实你是有权力了所以从ownership开始的话等于是一个非权的影响力那慢慢的当你真正的变成负责人的时候就是
非常和权责的影响力一起加在一起产生的一个效果对对因为就比如说我这个例子就是我们经常会有一些需要写就是宠购或者写数据的地方那但是呢你知道老板或者说是产品都是不可能给你这个时间啊说单独花一个月去宠购代码那这种时候呢你作为负责人你就需要去勾兑比如我们可不可以再做那个需求的时候嗯
就是稍微延长一天之类的半天我们把这个东西顺便改了就只能是就这种缝里边找时间来做嗯我明白嗯是的我理解了所以确实是也是一个比较有意思的过程但是呃你如果有on the ship的话你可能会做更多的事情但是你也会获得更多的机会他就是这样的一个过程吗对对然后对我其实我一直在想你刚才讲说要去跟他们battle啊所以所以你的演讲能力其实也在这个battle的过程中断言了很多对吧哈哈哈
对对对你必须要有理由去嘛不然你怎么battle赢嘛对有意思然后但但我觉得其实作为负责人本身也是挺就是会确实会比较辛苦吧就是确实需要更多方面能力就像刚才群里有一个我看那个直播间有个朋友说为什么刚才有个问题是没有接着聊直接篡下一个问题是因为刚才我临时处理了一点问题所以我其实都没有听
那个欧伯处在讲什么所以我当然也接不住他的话我又只能进入下一个问题了OK 没关系 没关系 我就解释一下那这个部分我觉得其实欧伯处的这些经验应该也是很有帮助的尤其是这个 ownership这个点大家一定要就是如果想从一个开发者往负责人方案走的话一定要把这个事情要重视起来OK 那刚才
我不会讲到一个点因为他刚才讲的这个后段很多都是围绕着一个语言展开的嘛那这个语言呢他又很神奇对吧是我们在社区会经常看到的一个文很有意思的语言所以我要问你一个特别有意思的送命的题啊我不知道直播间里面有没有别的语言站的同学看能不能去battle起来就是PHP为什么是世界上最好的语言这个问题请回答一下
这是一个千年老梗每个月都会有人出来说PP要完了所以我每次现在以刚开始说句心里话就是做一个PP开发者看到这些话的时候确实有点心寒或者有点烦躁但是现在其实无所谓了就是我会觉得说你开心就好
刚才也讲了我之前在知乎也经常跟人私嘛说16年以后我也不想跟人私了包括有时候在群里实在看不下去呢我就发表一下自己的观点就是因为我会觉得这个是一个屁股决定脑袋的事情就是我一直的观点是工具只是解决问题的用当你把它用好了那它就是非常牛逼的当你用不好那它再牛逼也是个废物所以呢
我为什么喜欢PVP就是因为它简单高效包括我平常也写HS所以我就喜欢它的自由简单那另外一部分人呢是那种就是他根本没有看他就他不知道PVP现在已经不是10年前的PVP了所以现在的PVP已经很很厉害了就是不管是性能还是余法各种都已经进步很大了这两年的变化非常快然后很多人就还在拿着老观点
那另外一部分就是刚才讲的屁股决定脑袋点他不用这个语言所以呢他偶尔就是拿来开开玩笑可能乐和乐和得那另外一部分人呢就是可能自己曾经是吧然后他现在转到其他语言了然后他转的原因呢有很多有一种是PV这个语言我确实写不好或者说我真的是写不得那么用不起来就是感觉另外一部分人就是跟风
PPP不行了我赶紧就换所以我不换的话我可能要饿死所以我就换本来于是就换其他语言所以然后呢他也自然就会屁股都坐到那边去了嘛那在别人喷呢或者别人开玩笑就跟着开嘛所以很多人其实也是无心的就是出个乐对吧所以我平常也是跟着大家乐所以他们说PPP要完我说是的估计也快了确实要完但是呢我从我们现在包括在公司包括这个项目都是在用PPP和Laura做这个项目
老板信任我因为他觉得我能把这个事情搞好我能用这个语言把这个问题解决好我们扣折单现在有几十万用户所以每天的上传的量啊各种问题都其实都是很活跃所以问题也不大就是我没有觉得说遇到语言的瓶颈我们甚至都没有用什么OSPOR或者是之类的工具来做解决性能问题真的没有遇到性能问题我这里说的老板不是马老板就是我们通常把自己小组的组长叫做老板
对 至于这个在中国什么PAP好不好找工作这种事情实际上首先一是我没有关注二呢他可能确实是由大家所说就是没有那么多职位但这个问题呢我个人首先我不关心所以呢如果他真的确实不行那如果你你毕竟在这里还是要生活嘛那确实哪个多哪个好证据去找哪个这个无可厚非没有任何问题所以呢单纯从语言的好坏来讨论的话就其实没有什么意义
你换句话说你说做PVP没有做某某语言好挣钱好找工作我觉得我都能非常赞同你的说法但是你如果上来真这个语言的好坏这个真的就是我觉得是没有什么意义的因为你如果用PVP写科物端去写ls那它确实是个垃圾但是如果你要用它来写后端的web的话我觉得没有任何语言能有它快能有它那么方便所以呢看个人的喜好你喜欢的它就是好的
对吧所以我觉得他在我心目中就是最好的当然js也是很好的因为我平常有写js所以我觉得他们都是最好的语言然后另外一点就是larvo很多人觉得larvo这个框架非常难那是因为你的pvp基础非常差所以你导致一些稍微有一点用到原特性的地方你都没有看得明白所以他一直被诟病的就是他的文档不那么亲民
这个点实际上我不是太赞同因为你连基础都不看的话你就想用好一个东西那确实换任何一个语言任何工具都会很难所以呢正因为larvo改变了pvp所以larvo是我最喜欢的框架也是我所有见到pvp开发者都去推荐的一个框架所以说评价一个东西的好坏要从要综合看全面去看
另外就是不要被这个语言所累死了就是不要觉得说自己就是个PAP开发者就像我从来不会说我是一个PAP程序员我甚至宁愿说我是一个Web开发者虽然我不敢自称为全站开发者但是我觉得我是一个Web开发者所以我不会说我就是个PAP开发者所以它只是工具你应该我一直有个观点是工程师最值钱的地方是解决问题的能力
所以你消化不了需求你没有Owner意识你解决不了问题换任何工具那可能都做不好所以不要老盯着性能这两个字而且它的性能确实也不差然后我想说的就是总结一下就是每个语言都有它适用的地方所以我对最好的理解就是每个人心里都有最好的语言没有必要争高低所以我会继续用到它
真的没有办法用的那天吗?可以 端水大师偶尔出上线了而且我觉得有一个点就是其实核心的有一个点就是说我们不能拿这个锤子就满世界找钉子嘛其实是要从问题的就我们讲其实我也很认同你说的工程师其实我一直会把工程师更加定义为叫问题解决者所以核心的出发点是问题是什么就它是不是个钉子对吧
他是不是个钉子我是不是要用一把锤子去去敲他这个我觉得这个才是这个问题核心的出发点OK我觉得当然跟这个问题本身可能没有太多关系但是我觉得从这个问题引申出来的这个点我觉得是很有意义很有价值OK那下一个点就是因为其实我觉得知道通过欧巴厨讲这些东西就是能看出来他其实是一直在不断的提升自己嘛所以我们其实很想了解一下就是
大家肯定会经常问嘛比如说我们今天看了一些书什么一百天学会什么五三十天精通什么也看到过很多这样类似这样的书所以可能会有一些人会问这样的问题就是有没有什么能快速提升自己的秘籍这个想看一下俄伟处你是怎么想这个问题的我的观点是其实真的没有速成的方法我觉得
它必须是通过一定量的积累但这个量可以是多方面的比如说那如果要做编程的话我觉得一定是靠写代码去学习的所以呢有一句老话说的好叫做写满十万行代码线所以如果你想变成一个有经验的或者入门的开发者先把代码量给积累上去你看得再多的书看得再多的教程
那些东西实际上是一个假象就是我觉得我看完就会了或者说很多人会说我们把收藏就会了对吧像平常买书一样我买来就会了这是个错觉然后你一定要去通过量就是去写不停地写不停地写那第二点就是拥有自己解决问题的方法那就刚才我讲的一点就是我们比如说去谷歌搜东西的时候
不要太口语化的去把这个问题描述得很复杂你只需要把关键词提取出来那可能解决问题会更快所以呢你需要有一套适合自己去解决问题的一个方法然后呢另外一点就是不要看视频去学东西那这个不是绝对不能啊就是我不推荐去看视频教程学东西因为
这个就会手摸手教东西也没什么区别就是它的点真的不在于说你不知道那个界面该怎么点你之所以不知道下一步可能是你前面的动作基础的东西没有做好你才不知道下一步该怎么走所以你才需要去看视频原来要点那个按钮要输入那个东西才能跑下去因为最大的问题是往视频看视频真的太花时间了可能一个小问题结果你花了半个小时花了20分钟所以真的
我推荐的是比如说你看一个东西就去看那个工具的官网去看他的手册看他的文档或者甚至去github就搜别人写过的同样的东西可能都比这个快我觉得那另外一点就是我个人的一个技巧就是希望大家有的人可能试用就是我要学一个新东西的时候我会尝试用这个新的东西造一个我熟悉的东西
比如说我曾经学node.js的时候那时候是13年还是多久13年的时候吧而我从周五开始我的目标是用node.js写一个带模板引擎的外部框架就是能输出一个页面就行能有路由功能就可以然后我就按照这个目标去做从周五晚上下班开始搞七八点开始搞一直搞到周日的中午
我两个晚上没有睡觉因为太兴奋了我就算尝试躺下睡我脑子里的全是代码所以睡不着我里面不睡我起来写到周日的中午大概11点多吧终于把那个基础的东西跑通了看起来会比较笨就是因为我完全没有时间去看教程去学所以我就不停地卡出问题不停地去搜问题不停地解决问题所以那个时候我的屏幕上应该是全是Google的那些Type打开的
页面所以最终把它实现了然后我就放手了那这个过程实际上你会觉得还蛮有成就感的虽然全是踩坑的过程所以我会经常用这个技巧去学东西就是用一个你不熟悉的东西造一个你熟悉的东西因为我用kb写一个外部页面我是非常熟练的怎么写路由啊都非常熟练所以我就尝试用no的去写一遍看怎么写于是呢这个过程当中就学会了很多
採了很多坑在採坑過程中你要去查手冊去看別人的答案所以就學到了東西所以這個可能會是相對比較快一點的學一個東西的方法一個技巧最後一點就是模仿和提煉那這個模仿怎麼講呢就是你平常在比如說就以我們PAP為主你想把你的PAP圓寫好把你代碼寫好那你怎麼叫好呢
比如我看一些框架的元代码比如Laro或者Sephony這些框架它就寫得非常的厲害你去看它們的代碼你就會在看的過程中學到原來這個東西還能這麼寫所以你在這個過程當中你就是模仿在你的業務代碼當中你嘗試性的用你看過的它們的一些寫法去寫寫一遍你得到了長到了甜點長到了好處
你就發現這樣寫還有用然後在這過程中你會去不斷的改進原來他那個不能直接用還得改寫一下所以在這個過程當中你就會去徹底理解為什麼他這麼寫這個模式有什麼好處所以這是一個模仿和提煉的一個方法那這個是我個人在這個提升自己方面的一些經驗所以我覺得密集還是有的就是歐洲處理大家分享了四點心法我覺得是
4点他觉得很有价值的心法但是我觉得他不是关于快速提升自己的是说能让你尽量去少走一些弯路的对吧一些心法还是没有价值非常感谢非常感谢我觉得如果有的同学觉得还ok的话也可以尝试一下直播间同学说非常受用还有说我乌乌很有价值很有价值真的ok那
刚刚关于你的部分其实我们讲了已经挺多的那其实可能也有一部分同学是对你现在所在的这个公司是比较感兴趣的对吧所以包括可能是你团队吧我们就想了解一下就是曾勋的工程示文化是怎么样包括可能曾勋太大了嘛你可以讲一讲你自己团队的这个工程示文化是什么样子可以给大家介绍一下好首先我看到这个问题的时候呢我觉得首先我没有
我沒有辦法去代替這個騰訊的公司來說話對吧我只是一個小小的羅斯丁然後呢另外就是像這種超多開發者的公司就是人太多了他的每一個部門可能都像一家公司甚至很多部門比很多公司都還要大比如說我們部門就有兩百多人那實際上沒有好多公司有兩百人以上那所以嚴格來講並沒有
统一的工程师文化这个说法但是这两年的公司也在内部去推这种基于工程师比如说代码规范啊各种工具啊还有测试啊去都在推进这些东西还有包括开源等等都在去培养这些就是希望会往一个好的方去赢的希望能做成像谷歌那样有一个非常厉害的工程师文化所以我觉得我没有办法去
概括这个所谓的腾讯工程师文化是怎么样但是在我们部门来讲首先在我进来之前我不是太熟是什么样子但是至少在我们Colysan这个团队里面我们后端的一些文化是这个样子首先就是你可以用任何你觉得有用的工具或者是方案去做一个需求
但是你需要考虑的就是你把优缺点都列出来你能说服大家去接受你的观点然后那你就可以去用你的工具甚至你想换个语言去写也没有问题但前提就是你能厚得住就是他出问题你不在或者有没有人帮你解决等等就是我们不封闭不拒绝你去做技术选心但是你需要有足够的说服力
然后另外呢就是我们的代码必须写测试我们写后端必须写集成测试没有要求写单元测试啊就写集成测试你就要把接口正向反向各种边界都要跑通然后覆盖度呢也是必须要达到90%就是接口层面必须达到90%以上呃然后我们的人不多所以呢这些实现起来问题还不大然后就是我们会要求写一些commit的message的时候都按照标准写分类等等所以不是很严格但是
我们尽可能的保证这个代码不会变烂变脏所以我们还会有代码规范的格式化工具命令航工具以及检查的我们会有自动化的检查等等还有流水线的去做测试教验等等所以其实还算一个基础的团队吧甚至我觉得并没有很多那些我之前见过一些小华美的公司做得好所以在我们这边是这个样子的OK 不好意思我刚刚又处理了一点现场问题
没关系那我就不总结了因为我看他确实没听到直播间同学如果大家觉得有什么价值或者说有什么问题可以问一问对因为我觉得我说他应该讲的挺多的对刚才露讲的一部分就是有扣的review扣review其实我们不会太
严格不会像很多那些有死板的流程必须两个人看完才能合并等等的我们可能就是如果复杂的一点就发到群里大家后段全部都看一遍等等那如果是一个非常简单的需求你觉得甚至都没有问题那我可能都不看那如果只是一个文件或者小部分的需求那我可能大家随便找个人过一眼approve以后就可以合并等等目前不招人因为你知道的全国都在这种裁员潮所以我们其实也没有坑位所以虽然非常人手不够但是
目前是没有坑位的这个游语戏是假的吧应该是假搞笑太逗了OK好我直播间是挺多人才对刚刚回到另外一个讲的就是讲一个点就是你讲刚刚讲的佛斯戴克这个点嘛虽然你说你自己不敢说你是一个佛斯戴克但是我觉得按照我们现在通用的定义来说确实是已经是佛斯戴克因为佛斯戴克我们家会定义是
外国家就是百刊子这样的一个角色所以我想了解一下这个Forsak给你带来一些什么样的好处我觉得最大的好处可能就是我想做一个事情的时候我不需要等待某一个人或者缺少某一个角色我可以从一个idea开始到做设计稿到写前端到写接口到最后部署我全都可以一个人搞定我觉得这可能是最大的好处
另外一方面的好处就是我我前后端都懂的话那我在工作当中也会比较顺利因为我做的接口我会让前端也比较好用甚至前端遇到问题我也可以去舍身处地的去想站在他的角度去理解为什么这里这样会有问题甚至我可能还会给一些经验不足的前端做一些指导等等所以整个工作环境就会变得非常的顺利所以这是另外一个好处就这两个
然后就结束了但是其实有很多好处了比如说你的眼界肯定会更多嘛你前端下面也可以看后端下面也可以看你可以从一些前端项目当中学到一些技巧你把它用到后端等等你可以看一些前端框架它的余法为什么可以这么巧妙你可以搬到后端去用等等所以其实你的眼界会变得更大
第一个其实还是那个点嘛就是你的基本思路就是你不干我就把你的活干掉然后第二个我确实很赞同就是其实我们在其实就是还是刚回到说解决问题那个点嘛就是当你的深度到了一定程度之后其实在很像上面如果有一些扩展我们今天要讲就是讲的很土的一句话就实自信人才嘛这个东西其实对你是会有一些肯定会有些帮助的
有一个东西你可能做到了90分然后其他还有一个方向你做到了80分那这个90加80就可能不是单纯的一个加法了它其实产生的这个能量会更大一些对 尤其是在工作中因为你是要跟不同的人去合作那如果你更了解他们的工作内容的话那你就会更容易相处对其实这个我想到一个点因为本身我就熟悉我的朋友知道我有平时会画画嘛就其实我自己可能也懂一点点设计
這個其實在我之前做移動端開發的時候我真的有很大的優勢就我去跟我們UI聊天的時候或者說做一些就設計還原的時候他們是非常非常喜歡的就是因為你懂這個設計所以你本身有一些美感所以在做前段頁面的時候你可能會更遵守就是更理解他們的一些想法這個確實是有對的對剛才有人問前後端比例其實我們差不多是二比一吧我覺得就是前端會比較多一點
因为你们那个产品更多的还是说是天在前端工作应该还挺大的对不对我理解因为你们的展现形式很多后端的话因为它本身我对于你们其实类似搭建系统那搭建系统它后面的逻辑本身设计完了之后基本上应该是固定了然后更多的可能还是说你在前端要做很多丰富的组件然后去让它有更强的能力对吧我不知道对这个产品的理解是不是对的
其实我们是一个就是设计交付平台就是如果用过蓝虎的应该知道其实我们和蓝虎就是差不多的进品了就是对所以对我会把那个网址发到我们的群里可以大家可以有兴趣的看推广一下推广一下OK没问题打个小广告嗯OK好的那我也回头好好了解一下嗯说不定我有一些免费的话能满足大部分小团队的需求
然后最后我再跟证就是长调一下这个叫co他的发音应该叫co design对吧不是co design对对对因为其实co那个co是cooperate就协作的意思对对对我知道因为有很多我看群里有人给他说co code3的问题就是他不是co code3他的读法是co design让大家关注一下这个不要多错好的那今天时间也不是很早的我们回到一个问题吧就是一个
大而全的問題啊就是這個後段開發者就從你的觀點來說後續我們怎麼去更好地去發展其實這個問題因為你其實我自己也沒有非常明確的答案因為剛才講我走到這條路呢實際上也是誤導誤撞因為也不是我的專業所以我個人來講我也並不想做什麼架構師專家等等因為我個人的愛好就是謝謝代碼所以我一直覺得說
我可能没有把自己当作一个纯后端去看待让我做前端我也可以所以当然现在做前端可能没那么专业所以严谨一点说是我希望我会在开发者这条路上继续走下去就是写更好的代码然后写自己满意的代码因为我每次回头看自己写过代码其实都不满意所以这个答案的
我很难给到一个非常有参考价值的答案所以我个人的观念是我的兴趣是喜欢写代所以可以发展的话可能就是继续写的更好一点更完美一点这个问题我觉得也留给我们直播间同学自己去思考一下或者我们这个问题先留着后续因为我们后面还有一些别的可能会有一些更
更資深的一些講師嘛就比如說包括我們下一期可能能看到就是比如說像那個太滴滴的這種總架構思啊他可能會來我們可以把這個問題到時候問問他看看他有沒有不同的想法所以我覺得就是因為後端其實有很多方向可以走比如說做架構思啊做專家呀等等就是我目前覺得就是我還沒有到那個理由然後我個人就是先繼續走下去就好了我明白後端的
对后端我觉得其实说实话后端怎么理解就是从天花板来说客观来说后端天花板确实要更高一些比如说我们讲这个我在大厂做研发这个系列活动说实话我们如果邀请移动端的移动端发展开发者可能邀请到类似P8就已经是极限了但是我们就是你会想啊比如说P8在网上它就不会再写代码了吗
对吧就很难说让他做讲来讲这个做研发这个话题但是你看看我们在讲那个后段部分的话比如说像我们下一场那个那个那个嘉宾确实他都已经到了总监级别了但是他还是能写的这个其实就是一个天花板的问题对比较刻意嗯OK行那我们
今天我觉得这个聊得很多我觉得挺开心的就一如既往的像我平时自己我们平时私下聊天那种感觉确实是聊得很舒服然后确实也很有收获吧我相信直播间的同学应该也会有一些相应的收获